it I think every time I've played neon
it has been a very very tight game so I
am expecting the same here let's see
neon DG 1 2 3 and my opponent is also a
strong player or excuse me a fast player
so let's go bird opening I'm gonna play
actually c5 right now ah and I'm gonna
get a little crazy maybe I'm gonna do
this so taking into account development
and space on this side of the board and
I believe let's throw another one up
here I don't want to allow this pawn
push to occur so easily and maybe just
make certain of this square right here I
don't that Knight posting up I'm not
quite sure what I want to do with my
knight I did for a brief brief second
think of f5 and the Knights Knight to f6
but that's killing my b6 square if I
ever if I even touch this pawn if he
moves a single square forget about it I
don't want the a file to open up so
let's go with this and maybe tonight
here right now
it's good money night out actually I
wanted to think a bit more about that
one
if pond push I think things get really
scary really fast something like pond
push I think is available so my opponent
is looking to get this efore advance in
and well they've been successful with
that hmm pawn push pond takes this is
getting really violent right here this
is this could blow up this could blow up
at any second
bunch of pond exchanges can happen in a
blink sea for I think takes is needed
Bishop recaptures pawn takes Bishop
takes I'm on the rook I'm gonna try it
I'm gonna try it knowing the following
this is the main point in me going for
this it's that I want to open up the
position knowing that this king is the
more vulnerable of the two that are on
the board also I am open to the
following I am open to giving up this
rook and I think we could be seeing that
take place very soon with the knight
move right here or something I'm okay
with giving up this guy he's extremely
important to be hanging on to so also if
there's a capture away from the center I
have the d4 square available to land
checks so let me start with first this
move it seems very purposeful off the
diagonal support the bishop discovered
checks are in the air
also there's Queen b6 moves picking off
this pawn a lot of pressure my Knights I
think all my pieces are now working and
again I have the safer King so I think
these are
well this is compensation that's what
I'm trying to get its compensation for
me being down upon right now a lead in
development is another one if the bishop
plays here there's like night moves but
still this is the the main issue so far
a night block I think is met with a
check and then this and now I think we
have something like chasing the Queen
off of this diagonal
maybe there's something against this
bishop too in some lines Knight right
here looks really really appealing I
think I'm actually going to do that in
sack another pond and I think I'll be
able to take up post on this square I
hear my idea is to block the Queen from
this diagonal and now get ready for some
check here whether it be Bishop or
Queens so I miscalculated I think or did
I that's a third pun but I think I now
end up killing my opponent here
I think they end up having to run into a
nasty discovered check or is that really
the case so wait a second I'm thinking
of actually a rook move in a better work
actually it better work as if it doesn't
I'm a dead man it's not really working
no it's not really working
I could take here they could take my
knight I could take the rook hmm I don't
want to take Queen takes and then
there's this Knight falling so if I
don't have these tactics working out
then I think I'm in some trouble let's
see hopefully it's working less than two
minutes to figure it all out
rook here Bishop takes Queen now that
would work what am I saying
I got to try this yeah I definitely have
to try that I'm on the rook on the
bishop
whoa wasn't expecting that okay I get
better get some material here it's my
dark squares that are very weak right
now I want to get rid of this light
square bishop or something real soon
let's go here
oh the bishop right here is uh something
something's going on with that oh the
Queen was hitting my knight I don't even
realize what I want to do it my queen
keep pressure on this night I have very
little time Bishop here maybe no there's
this it's my night gonna be kicked away
okay that's a pretty good defense right
there can I allow for that that trade
it's not really fantastic for me is it I
should probably avoid the exchange that
pond that bishops really annoying oh man
I'm in trouble
I'm in big trouble right here the
Knights gonna be a killer I got to get
rid of that Knight can I get rid of it
I'm in trouble less than a minute tick
tick tick tick tick I gotta get rid of
the night before it lands here my
Knights they are covering just in time
could I pin the night let's get here I'm
on that Bishop there's takes right there
and that's threatening me oh it's scary
if this Bishop gets on the diagonal I'm
a dead man less fifty seconds Oh super
super critical right here on that bishop
can the Queen even defend it whoa oh
yeah the Queen could defend it get rid
of this rook then look for back rank
stuff oh it was on my queen I don't even
realize that a pig I want a pig pigs
pigs pigs give me the pigs I don't have
anything I'm on the bishop there's rook
checks but they probably shouldn't do
that I'm my rook I gotta go here to
defend I have nothing I'm a dead man
I gotta go here is the rook gonna give a
check 28 seconds am I getting mated I
getting mated petrel check the rook left
the back rank um making one threat do I
have this 21 seconds this is made that's
me by the skin of my teeth
oh I was dead I should have been a dead
man oh man I got away with one there
neon should have beaten me up right
I pulled a rabbit out of a hat man that
was a classic rabbit out of the Hat
stuff going on there well okay let's
have a look back here Wow
things got really out of hand let's back
up let's see okay so I want to make sure
I get on this diagonal space advantage
as well with v5 looks fun
looks very dynamic white's idea is to
get in this efore advanced this is these
are all prep moves this decent d3 this
c3 movement it is all indirectly or
directly facilitating efore I say
directly because okay the pond on d3 is
already supporting this c3 more so
indirect it's allowing for the Queen
take up a post on c2 and have efore come
in so I think I would actually still
play this again this c4 move I like it I
like the compensation I got but I think
I might have missed some knockout rook
here the Queen move should I have given
up this pond I didn't I didn't see the
Queen coming over to grab here ah I
don't know there's no way I'm gonna be
able to run all the numbers on this and
know what is vast ins in such a blown
open position like this but at least if
there is something to take away know
that you know the thoughts I was sharing
on this the these are the forms of
compensation I was seeing just the
exposed the more exposed King and the
lead and development that I have here
but my opponent does in the meantime
pickoff count at one two three pawns
these three all being passed but I am
able to be putting some pressure on here
I would like to get to this square
without giving up my dark square bishop
like
if this night could just not be there
maybe there's could I go with the Queen
move maybe there's something more subtle
here maybe Queen to d3 or something is
better I'm trying to find improvements
for myself because I was definitely
worse off in that final position I do
see a clearer way that white could have
been winning I think just continuing to
push with the H pawn check yeah there's
some something tells me there should be
something more because the bishop blocks
and my knight is dead this is uh this is
a good one I mean the bishop controls
this diagonal so the King is a bit more
safe now and I think there were multiple
ways that my opponent could have been
killing me so I'm trying to find
improvements before here for me
I wonder if there's something more
something tells me this is still okay I
don't know about that though
I don't know I don't know I don't know
what to say beyond good game this good
defense very very resourceful giving
back some material right here I do see a
way that you could just kill me right
where as soon as the Queen's are off and
I totally overlooked this that the Queen
was even being attacked just keep
pushing the pond right okay Bishop move
is good push the pond and push the pond
one more the both the bishops are
covering those I'm dead
keep the rook right here on the back
rank I have nothing if there's anything
I have to have these guys trained on
this second rank but okay there's a main
threat I'm able to weasel away but now
there's made threats so yeah I think
just in this position the bishop move is
good as a follow-up after I do this and
I'm off the second a78 I'm have to tip
over my king there's nothing okay I
actually have to give up a rook for a
pawn sad situation all right let me
close out